whoa hey what's going on everybody for
first weave feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today I'm joined by post Malone
what's going on brother he's fresh off
the purposed tour Justin Bieber in his
debut album Stoney is set to drop on
December 9th hosts welcome to the show
thank you for having me brother how are
you with hot food I mean I like it I
don't know how I feel about about this
whole setup over here like them with the
Megadeth sauce I mean I really feel it
in my stomach I feel like it's just
gonna be a hell of a trip and a hell of
a trip to the toilet later I'm ready to
get weird
[Music]
boneless wings for post Malone come on
boy the best I'm very lazy I have very
dainty fingers delicate fingers so I
can't really get into that type of stuff
I never charge for watching do you like
it yeah
are zingy so you credit Guitar Hero for
inspiring you to learn guitar and in a
way kind of paving the way for your
music career I feel like there's a lot
of people that are like you know why
play guitar hero when you could play
real guitar right and you know Prince
said that - as long as you develop a
love for music any way that you develop
it and you take it - you know the real
world I feel like it's you know I feel
like it's the same are there any other
games that kind of mirror your life any
other ones that are super important to
you Skyrim you don't need friends with
that video game you just get lost and
live your life you're the Dragonborn bro
you do whatever you want so whatever
that's a great flavor you burst on the
scene in such a fast and extreme way and
when that happens I sometimes wonder if
these sort of on the come-up
coming-of-age moments ever match up to
the dreams of the fantasies that you
have for them so I want to give you some
and then you can kind of tell me if it
lived up to the hype or if it was a
little disappointing okay cool let's do
it
what about your first red carpet do you
remember that I remember my first red
carpet it was super awkward whenever
people hype me up or whatever I feel
like I don't meet the expectations so
I'm just like I don't know what what you
wanted me to do I don't know it's like
Ricky Bobby yeah it's like what do I do
with my hands Oh your first time flying
private that was worth it I think my
first time fine private I was going to
Vegas with Scott and we got the smoke on
there and how about the first famous
person to come up to you as sort of like
in a fan way I think I think my first
experience really came through social
media like well Wiz Khalifa and Mac and
that was super dope but I think my first
time on the street was on Fairfax I was
just walking down and someone can take a
picture in it's a crazy feeling that's
when you're like oh [ __ ] it's happening
[Music]
because they'd be chili habanero how was
that one pretty good yeah good you have
the unique distinction of having worked
with Kanye West and Justin Bieber who
are a couple guys you know their
personal lives they seemed so
impenetrable and but people are so
fascinated by them and I know that
you're way too much of a gentleman to
give me any sort of details and I
respect that
but I do wonder just seeing the way
those guys move this scene the way they
worked the stage seeing how they are in
the studio do you see any similarities
between the two
they're so driven like they're so driven
to like a complete a task they start
something they're gonna finish it every
time I don't know how he does a show
every night for two hours for almost a
year every night like he's a superhuman
how about two for you you know going
from kind of playing small stages at
South by Southwest to all of a Sud
being on the purpose tour was there some
sort of like superstar crash course that
you had to go through or did they just
sort of send you out there in front of
all those people and her like perform
your son that's the craziest thing ever
walking out to a stadium audience right
you don't know if they're gonna like him
the first time I came out there
everybody was singing the song and
everybody knew the words to the song I
was so nervous and it never got better
the whole time Billy every time you take
the stage same yeah no it's the same
feeling it's terrifying because you're
in like weird places like Saskatoon
right and broken tree Iowa I don't know
if that's a place but it sounds like it
yeah no it sounds good I feel like I
need to see your bites and see what kind
of bite you're taking so that you can
gauge mm-hmm or are you like one of our
commenters and you think there's like
some sort of conspiracy and I'm not even
actually taking bites some no I'm a
conspiracy guy but you are yeah so this
next part of the show is called explain
that gram and you've seen the show
before so you know how it works we've
done a deep dive on your Instagram we
pulled some pics that we think need more
context we'll just show you the picture
and you tell me the bigger story okay
mm-hmm laptop please hell yeah that's a
strong man all right so this one's
interesting you and Husain bolt
yeah we were in London and we went to
this place called Cirque I think he was
there randomly and it was a weird clubs
like a weird satanic live like people
dancing with masks on and real ones next
to us there was a lady with a big-ass
cloud hat it was just a cloud with rain
coming down it wasn't a lady it was a
boy but it looked like a lady what about
this hell yeah you and Toby Keith you
know it was one of the dopest nights of
my life
it was his birthday I think we're in
Connecticut SEAL Team six was there the
guys that killed Osama they were all get
got in free and everything and so he
invited me on the bus and we just drank
and played guitar and just jammed for
like two hours with with the with the
guys that killed Osama bin Laden
on the bus we text sometimes I was like
whatever it's me whatever you and Jaden
yeah I look fat Jin looks good though
that was on the purpose tour at MSG and
they were tripping and they didn't want
to let me backstage cuz they were like
who's this homeless person I didn't say
that but that's what you could read it I
said hey I'm opening for addressing
Bieber dude so if you could like just
let me in bro this is interesting you
and Justin Bieber the [ __ ] you post cups
set up did you guys set up the cups the
cops were they already set up I didn't
do that he did that just ease a little
pranks here a little goose leg after
okay tell me about doesn't break these
it took him some time it took him at
least an hour he put some thought into
it really smells like full-blown art
knowledge no there's art this is art
like we wanted to make this a mixtape
cover or something he got me good I
still haven't got him back yet I think I
must steal his dog that's good watch out
for Esther man yeah yeah yeah
I got you you know it this is the best
sauce kit thank you
well it's gonna make you both and that's
a good sauce I respect your aesthetic
what do you think of the bottle what do
you think of the design I think it looks
great I think it's minimalist mm-hmm
that's what you're going for I think it
really speaks for itself
it's got a great texture you're a guy
who started getting tatted when you
really started making money and drawn
eyeballs and just judging by what I'm
looking at right now that ship has
definitely left the port do you still
have what do you have for feet you have
four faces or you have five yeah 5 9
yeah um this one's still healing this is
George Harrison so that must be new yeah
that's very new you know who's next on
your fingers I want to do Hank Williams
senior Jim Morrison Stevie Ray Vaughan
bankroll I think I might I might have to
take this one do one here and do one
here just to fit onto legend zone I got
on my steve-o wave okay so I got me
tatted on me really but it's more of a I
have a picture does somebody have a it's
me on a horse it's not done yet
it's me on a horse it's subtle it's not
like it doesn't sound subtle it's not a
big ass picture on my face on my back
something it's like it's so we we found
a picture of a guy on a horse riding and
we just put my face on it but it's tiny
it's like that big could you hold this
up to that camera that's uh no you
should see it's like this big and nobody
would notice unless I told them it's
Muruga blood-orange scorpion pepper
sauce mm-hmm it's quite a title I always
jump into it at this point and you hate
your life mm-hmm pose I don't like it
now you know what Sam I like it now
you'll get it
now you understand it yeah that's good
Wow once again I'm gonna bust out the
laptop because we got more pictures to
look at because whenever you take
pictures with animals the internet goes
crazy all over the in too much cuteness
it's so much cuteness so what I'm gonna
do is once again show you some of these
pictures and you can tell me Oh what's
happening okay this animal is and how a
failure my [ __ ] that's a large crowd
so this is a large sea creature we were
in Maine yeah we were in Maine we just
had done a show he said yo we make a
shitload of money doing lobsters not
doing lobsters but like selling lobsters
trying pool so I figured you know what
let me go see what it's about
let me see if I want to open up my own
Lobster Shack was smart so he showed me
this big-ass Lobster and I said let me
hold it talk to you about Branson yeah
that's my little guy I want him to sleep
all day me but he doesn't he's pulling
our G yeah he's a lot and he's got a lot
of energy he loves to eat shoes I know
this typical dog stuff but ones like the
most expensive clothing item he's he's
eaten he had a my Gucci loafers and I
didn't really appreciate that
hidden top 100 years up in there mm-hmm
milk I'll help a little bit ah [ __ ] yet
it it's impossible to do a puzzle
interview without talking about clothes
whether it's gold teeth it's cowboy
boots it's high-fashion you definitely
have a look that's all your own and I
think your fans might be surprised or at
least some of them that this is not a
new development it's in true your
stepmom she's tough to press your suits
we need go to junior high you'd wear
suits in junior high I had to have I had
to have everything on fleek
that's a very interesting thing for
someone who's in middle school to do to
come to school every day in a suit well
I wanted to be my dad so I would stick
my hair back right short hair and I just
see no tucked in my shirt there had to
everything perfectly pleated and
perfectly starched um
I was super five but how did the kids in
junior high treat the kid who wears a
suit to school every day is that a cool
thing to do or do they tease you and
they make fun of you this is a great
question you know I've had my fair share
of kids you don't gum in my hair
please to throw up government look at me
now [ __ ] I'm even hot very hot
wait
but you know um it was tough I have my
own I was an individual and people don't
like that right people don't like when
you're different from them in you and go
against the norm this wing is hot but I
respect you because you did it every day
anyway
yeah [ __ ] and I stood to [ __ ] I still
do [ __ ] only you can appreciate the
genius that is you and everybody has a
genius in themselves because at the end
of the day you're not gonna die with the
feelings of these people you're gonna
die it yourself right so you just have
to love who you are and do what you want
to do whatever makes you happy
swak yeah it's time for this already God
Jesus Christ are we moving a little too
fast for you well [ __ ] that how you
feeling hon you know what do [ __ ]
wrong it finally pocket [ __ ] it and try
to get him up and go lit as fast as
possible so I want to talk to you about
chicken Express what were you where yah
where you at the register where you in
the kitchen when you work that chicken
Express what were you doing um a little
bit of everything I started out as a
packer and a packer and you see the
order on the screen yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
whoever made this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
psychopath sociopathic goddamn as a
connoisseur of fast food I feel like
you're the perfect person to put some of
these regional fast food debates to rest
because the South I think you know a lot
of people think in the west coast and
the East Coast is kind of like where
these are fought but the South dominates
please are you a Raising Cane's guy or
as Zaxby's guy there's no contest who's
raising cans all the way it's got that
crisp to to chicken ratio and I think
for me the zach sauce is way too salty
chick-fil-a or Bojangles chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a why it's like a sit-down
restaurant that is fast food I think
it's the best airport restaurant what do
you think of that I agree we're gonna
agree with you you went from Texas to LA
so I think that you can chime in on this
one what a burger or in a now please bro
please and it out is like a [ __ ] will
like it's really little patty bro I need
something with some [ __ ] hair on his
chest cut how you feeling
it ain't even that hot it ain't even
that humma you got me fired up with that
water burger come here bro come on you
already know Gavin [ __ ] that way hmm
I know your life long Dallas Cowboys man
take a lap post lots of laps in this
room I don't need my hurt though
we don't even hurt that's the best part
I came in here what was it like to play
Jerry Jones's holiday party it was fire
what do you remember about that night my
dad performing with me your dad
performed with you at Jer Jones's party
what'd you guys perform write a verse in
my only good song
I ain't too young G best song thank you
sir appreciate you [ __ ] you for giving
me this wing No
whoa all right this last wing used
Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
and Megadeth is a great band and so is
Rage never advanced well together we'll
see how this smoothie works out juice
then add some base we dab the last wing
it's sort of a tradition around here
post you don't have to if you don't want
to that's why I thought this was going
my sinuses clear it up right I've never
felt better
that's enough for me
I can't I'm losing vision does it feel
kind of good don't stop fly like a
[ __ ] dude stop doing that move bro
you're bloom I'm spilling everything
over here every time I move the table
that's alright that's alright it's on us
we have a very wobbly table here it has
been flake 50 I suppose like a piece of
paper do you think you could yeah do
something are you kind of here don't you
help you know I'm a handyman
I appreciate that maybe were to take a
look but before you take the bite here's
my question it's a very big time for
sauce Cowboys receiver cold Beasley too
much sauce when he dances Gucci worried
about getting lost in the sauce
allows you but you also get lost in the
South you can't wait to and then you
sawsan on you Sasa not everybody what I
want to do is barber dine I'm this sauce
which happens to be Blair's Megadeth
sauce with liquid rage we want you to
take a bite and then try to explain to
me what sauce is exactly when you're
when you say i'm saucin on you what the
hell does that even mean
does that sound good like cheers post
cheers brother
oh yeah she's just Christ who the [ __ ]
is dog I love others Jupiter now sauce
to me and then it's the way that you
carry yourself what makes you an
individual's um they know what makes you
you what makes you unique and what makes
you better than somebody who hates you
hatice's having toured the country which
city has the most sauce palace made the
most sauce at Kylie Jenner's birthday me
was your favorite chick-fil-a sauce is
that pollination sauce it's the buffalo
sauce the buffalo sauce is the best post
you made it through you cleared the
board it was incredible
it was intense did you have fun doing it
good answer this camera is that camera
or that camera let the people know what
you have going on in your life what's
going on y'all this is post e we got an
album coming out December 9th it's
called Stoney it's the best thing I've
ever heard
I hope it's the best thing you've ever
heard it's lit
turn up fought this week
respect mr. bash